welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season 6 episode 3 titled bethic
instinct to the Thanksgiving episode
where the turkey isn't the only bird
getting their gut stuffed and eaten with
the family oh my God it's disgusting
between this and the incest baby Morty
and summer are gonna need so so much
therapy let's be honest but that's why
they paid Dr Long the big bucks let's
get into the dirty details you might
have missed in this wonderfully Awkward
episode brought to you courtesy of
venusian wine hooray but first do not
forget to hit up the rockstarsmerch.com
to pick up our newest latest Obsession
shirts inspired by both House of the
dragon and She-Hulk and they're not
gonna last forever so hit up in
rockstarsmerch.com today so you can be
rocking some cool t-shirts in style all
right so the episode is titled the
bethic instinct which is a play on the
1992 movie Basic Instinct which is a
movie that features a bisexual character
named Beth who has an intimate sexual
history with the film's main suspect
Catherine who has a questionable
potentially murderous past which kind of
mirror Earth best relationship with the
more quicker to murder space Beth and
the episode starts with Morty setting up
a poop licky in gamepod XL which is a
slight mishmash parody of Nintendo's
GameCube and 3DX XL consoles and
apparently a console that allows the
users to play an infinite amount of
ultra realistic games like a video game
version of interdimensional cable but if
you notice here the console glows pink
like the crystallized xanthanite that
Rick installed into the family cable box
so that they can watch interdimensional
cable a crystal with the capability of
messing with time and Alternate
timelines which is why it is mainly
referred to as a Time Crystal Rick uses
this Crystal in the season to Premiere A
Wrinkle in Time when Rick tries to
repair the splintered realities caused
by Morty in Summer's uncertainties a
crystal that time cops like slimy pants
will arrest you for as they are highly
illegal to have so having space bath
carelessly gives us to Morty is very in
line with her badass nature then Rick
smashes into the glass in Turkey form
before reverting back and saying pardon
the interruption we are once again in
the federal clear which is a callback to
see and 5 episode 6 Bank exploitation
spectacular when Rick and Morty turned
themselves into turkeys to get pardons
from the presidents and it appears that
Rick has succeeded yet again and it kind
of sounds like Rick has done this
annually for a long time because when
Rick tries to bail on both bets one of
them notes
implying that Beth is well familiar with
Rick's Thanksgiving turkey Dracula
pardoned Shenanigans and at Jerry's
request before dinner Rick presses a
button on his watch that causes his
outfit to emerge from underneath his
skin much like Iron Man's extremist
armor from the comics which is yet
another Iron Man reference from Rick
after he pretends not to know who Iron
Man is I don't have a helmet like that
Avengers guy did in the season 6
premiere and after dinner Earth Beth
offers Jerry's man cave as a place for
space Beth to sleep to which spacebath
replies well that's okay I'll sleep in
my car it's got a tardis thing going on
bigger on the inside which is a
reference to my favorite TV show of all
time Doctor Who a show about a space
nerd who travels space and time in a
blue police box called the Tardis that
is much bigger on the inside than the
outside it's bigger on the inside is it
I noticed and Rick not liking Doctor Who
type Shenanigans is also very much in
line with his character in The Rick and
Morty Comics which you should definitely
read by the way because in the very
first issue of those comic series it is
very clear that he has a hatred for the
Doctor Who parody Professor talk the
time detective he really does not like
time trouble and when spacebath fixes
Earth's Beth's back problem I couldn't
help think that this is a shout out to
the Spider-Man no way home moment when
Andrew Garfield cracks his Toby Maguire
variants back
yeah that's good and both baths sip wine
that is from Venus venusian wine which
is a planet named after the Roman
goddess of love sex and desire which
could potentially serve to explain why
the venusian language is literally just
French one of the most romantic
languages in the world
and potentially as well as the entire
Beth Romance of this episode as the wine
could have some love potion-esque
attributes which might serve to explain
why Rick puts the venusian wine in his
secret pocket reality wine shelf and
then garbage disposed of the key he's
just like it's too powerful this this
alcohol is too powerful it makes my
daughter a two a lesbian for herself a
secret shelf that also had a liquid with
a little baby Morty in it this be what
Rick drinks to camouflage his brain
waves with Morty waves whenever Morty
can't tag along with them
is with a Morty the genius waves get
canceled out by the uh
Morty waves we love backstory here on
new rock stars and some of our favorite
character reveals are all about who's
related to who and here's the thing it's
fun when it's fictional characters
family's trees that you're digging into
but it can be really frustrating when
it's your own family tree and that's
what my Heritage is for my Heritage is
the leading global Service for family
history research and DNA testing is
trusted by 90 million users because my
Heritage not only makes building your
family tree easy and fun it also gives
you access to powerful tools that can
help you research your family history
and flesh out that family tree here at
new Rockstar Zach using my Heritage to
find out more about his family and learn
that his great great grandfather was
born in the Treviso region of Northern
Italy in 1853 no joke his name was Luigi
and they also had census documents with
his relatives names on them from 1903
and he's super excited to continue to
learn more about his family history my
Heritage is home to more than 18 billion
easily searchable historical records 18
billion and myheritage also has advanced
AI Technologies for repairing enhancing
colorizing and animating historical
photos so if you got a photo of your
great grandparents that can use a little
TLC my Heritage has got you covered sign
up for a 14 day free trial and enjoy all
the amazing features my Heritage has to
offer and if you decide to continue your
subscription click the link below and
get a 50 discount Rick Morty and Beth
then play an unnecessarily realistic
gamepod version of asteroid for the
Atari where they end up floating in
empty space doing nothing with the
ability to leave a message for their
fictional in-game loved ones in case
they die like Iron Man did for pepper in
endgame as he was floating through the
void of space and when earthbath gives
space Beth a massage outside when they
can't sleep Earth bath calls space bath
a space cowboy which is likely a
reference to Cowboy Bebop a Sci-Fi anime
that ends each episode with the words
see you space cowboy I really love that
show you should watch it probably not
the Netflix version and when summer
decides to stress play video games after
her mom's almost kiss her and Rick are
playing a street roaming Street Fighter
parody called getting to a street fight
which is hilarious considering that the
new Street Fighter 6 game has Street
roaming capabilities as well and
apparently the Rick and Morty Universe
has space swales much like one of the
most underrated Disney movies of all
time that definitely needs a live-action
remake Treasure Planet a space whale
that Rick is getting to make controller
please don't do animal abuse for video
games but as he's doing this Rick
extends a robot arm to grab a saw
furthering the Reed Richard's parallels
of the show likes to make with Rick's
character much like the Council of
Rick's is pretty much a parody of the
Council of reads from the Marvel Comics
and as both Beth space Vape on the roof
after a quick self-love mouth session
they lie on two snow angels holding
hands that they made symbolizing their
Unity but what's super interesting here
is that when they blow out their smoke
whatever is currently at their mind at
the moment is what takes shape so space
path blows out a middle finger after
thought of giving the family an
explanation for what they're doing and
earthbath blows out a Jerry shape while
thinking about her marriage that feels
pretty fun we then see summer and Morty
playing a hilarious realistic variant of
Final Fantasy VII where Cloud just can't
get it up just can't he can't do it
better get a Bluetooth clown I'm just
kidding I'm about his Buster sword that
realistically should not be easy to lift
and swing at all have you ever seen the
size of that thing like you you need to
like be I don't know Terry Crews to to
even lift that like an inch off the
ground and when Rick busts the bath
smooching in his hollow deck he directly
references the San Junipero episode a
Black Mirror one of the most popular
episodes of the series that follows two
lesbian lovers in a simulated reality
then space Beth immediately threatens
earth's best family by saying that she
has all the weapons from the Predator
franchise which I thought was pretty
cool and I hope we see more of those
weapons in action hopefully to kill
Naruto the baby out in space
but anyways when spacebest spills the
beans on her secret masturbate dates
with Earth Beth Jerry activates his
latent pill bug shell that apparently
activates during periods of emotional
distress much like real pill bugs do
when they feel danger Rick installed
this when they were both drunk together
one time the same day he got a tattoo of
both him and Jerry as Eagles on his pale
white ass look at that ass so pale so
great with Jerry's face and wings
looking way less confident than Rick's a
man who is way more than familiar with
being a bird he apparently loves it like
a lot he I think Rick obviously just
wants to be a bird or a pickle but
mostly a bird Rick then heads back to
the gamepod with his kids very high to
play a realistic text-based video game
about being stuck in a forest a style of
game much like 1976's Colossal Cave that
was very popular in the past before all
them fancy polygons you kids love hit
the scenes all these polygons and video
games that can't even handle it back in
my day Tomb Raider had
and I really love how Morty says how old
are we we've had a million thanksgivings
which is basically Morty breaking the
fourth wall by calling out how cartoon
families like The Simpsons or Family Guy
or even American Dad never really age
despite experiencing the same holidays
over and over again however this could
also be a subtle reference to how Morty
lived billions of lives in the last
episode when summer did a die hard to
save him he literally experienced
billions of thanksgivings himself and
when the baths Force Rick to whip out
the memory wiping machine from Morty's
mind blowers so they can forget about
their whole Affair Rick says you guys
are having the Eternal Sunshine all the
multiplicity porn scenes from your minds
stay sounds right which are references
to both 2004's Eternal Sunshine of the
Spotless Mind and movie where Jim Carrey
memory wipes a past relationship and
1996's multiplicity a movie where
Michael Keaton clones himself to try to
be more efficient in his job and family
life and I thought it was hilarious how
Rick calls Jerry a cuckold husband to
the best because it is very much some
foreshadowing to the threesome death
occurs at the very end of the episode to
the hilarious horror of the children and
speaking of when Morty is asked what
he's thankful for he says the Discovery
Channel which is a quite timely
reference considering that Warner
Brothers and Discovery just merged and
they own the rights to Rick and Morty um
so thank God for monopolies because they
made a quick joke about it sorry Batgirl
and at the very end of the episode I
thought it was a really nice touch how
space Beth mentions Morty and Summer's
incest baby Naruto from season 5 episode
4 because it kind of felt like a slight
jab of the kids for judging her in Earth
Beth's relationship and what they did
come on guys uh don't forget about your
incest baby this isn't that weird and
finally we have the return of the Jerry
Beret daycare center from Season 2
Episode 2 Morty Knight run when Jerry
returns to try to kiss himself like his
wife did typical Jerry move part of me
does wonder how Jerry even got there
considering that Rick's portal gun Got
Hijacked at the end of the season 5
finale but the Jerry Berry does exist on
a cross-temporal asteroid for Brook that
is sort of a Nexus point of all
realities so theoretically Jerry could
have just flown there with Rick's ship
on autopilot but that is it for this
breakdown of season six episode three of
Rick and Morty what'd you guys think of
the episode what would you even call
this is it masturbation is it incest let
us know in the comment section below and
of course do not forget to hit up the
rockstarsmarch.com so you can find all
of our amazing shirts and amazing nerd
gear over there and those new obsession
shirts are not gonna last forever so
pick them up today you can follow me at
masterton on Twitter if you want to see
me tweet some weird [ __ ] and really fun
theories but more importantly you can
fall into rockstars wherever we are on
the social media thank you guys so much
for watching this video I love you guys
so much and I'll see you guys later
goodbye all right cool beans
foreign
[Music]
[Music]